serious because you've lived like
everywhere yeah what what is your
experience dating in different countries
so I lived in Poland Ukraine and I often
talk on my channel that the the women
are just much more family oriented it's
almost almost like the US like 50 years
ago so it's like they're more like
feminine elegant
um kind of stronger moral system looking
for kind of family stuff like that
on on the flip side of the coin they
take longer to hook up with which was
annoying right like in Ukraine it would
take like two to five dates to actually
hook up with a girl added situations
where I've been a fourth date in public
and they weren't ready to kiss you which
I've never encountered anywhere else but
there's not a lot of this you know
um kind of me too stuff that's happening
in the US and happening in in the UK and
stuff like that but again these are very
real problems that need to be addressed
but when they say that you can't speak
about
you know hooking up with a girl with an
earshot of another woman or you can't
brush up against someone even if it was
an accident or stuff like this it starts
to blur the line between you know guys
just living their life